[Music]
this morning amore tolls and the lincoln
highway it was named the best book of
the year by amazon and six months after
publication is still on best seller list
as more people discover its unique
charms the lincoln highway is much
different than what tolls has done in
the past including the hits rules of
civility and a gentleman in moscow both
of which have sold more than a million
copies
to hear more about it we visited tolls
in upstate new york
i didn't know what the lincoln highway
was before i started this when did you
first neither did i right
amor tolls was four years into
developing his latest book
before he found the most important parts
it was always going to be about a group
of kids in the 1950s who set out on a
road trip
then he discovered a widely forgotten
piece of history
the first road that stretched all the
way across america from times square in
new york city to san francisco and so i
went down the little rabbit hole of
trying to find out what the lincoln
highway was and everything i learned it
was like a gift
everything about it was perfect for my
story and so instantly it became central
to the story and actually you know
listen to as long as he's here this is
the original
notebook of the story which was dates to
2014. cool
yeah and it was called unfinished
business is what the that was the first
title that's what the title was
but then you can see later on it you
know it becomes
the lincoln highway the lincoln highway
is told from four different perspectives
we won't spoil anything but you may find
yourself figuring out which personality
you are
and who your friends are
tol says he always knew who he was from
first grade on
a writer
but he took a massive detour after
college accepting a job in finance he
was warned by one of his mentors when i
went to wall street he said every young
person of town i've ever known has gone
to wall street they never come back you
know and you should assume
that your life as a writer is over
now that you're working on wall street
for almost two decades it sort of was
until he found the time to write a novel
about a year in the life of a determined
young woman in the new york city of the
1930s
in 2011 it was a surprise hit
that was followed by an even bigger one
five years later the story of a man
imprisoned in a russian hotel the first
book is called rules of civility second
book gentleman in moscow both
civil i mean in different ways but about
civility yes the lincoln highway yeah is
not it's not
uncivil it's very unsuitable yes and you
know i think as a novelist for me i like
to move from one project to something
which is which is different and shape
and form and tone
and so the shift in the general in
moscow from
a very sophisticated aristocratic
individual
you know in a 30-year tale where he
doesn't leave a building it was fun to
go deal with 18 year old boys who were
uncivil
on a you know on a road trip for 10 days
in essence you went from a career
where you're dealing with people all the
time yes constant interactions that's
right to
isolation yeah what is that like
i well i like it
but i i i think you know when i had a
former colleague who said what would it
take to get you to come back and i was
like a gun and handcuffs you know
because but i think like a lot of a lot
of writers we are comfortable with
solitude this is one of the places you
write yes this is where i work out when
i'm out here that's right do it is it
the yellow submarine it is that was for
my kids
and we have i mean we've got you have
inspiration right here yeah i mean
i'm a big fan of the
you know the american renaissance the
19th century figures who kind of created
american discourse so that's walt
whitman emerson throw and moby dick
those are my night those are my high
school copies it's not a terrible
foursome
no that's right
toll's process is distinct he doesn't
really do any on the ground research
instead letting his imagination run wild
the outlining process in notebooks takes
years
i try to write things that i know a lot
about already so i can imagine them
fully and when and i postpone any
applied research until i'm finished
writing the first draft and then i'll go
and check some things and and ideally to
catch the mistakes that people are going
to email me about later
it's almost like facts can get in the
way of the truth absolutely
i think that there's and in poetry
that's true right that's not true in
government
no but it is true i don't want to people
you can easily misinterpret that but i
think you know what i'm talking about no
absolutely because when you're trying to
tell a human a human story uh the
the truth of it is is in
the poetic imagination toll's success in
two different careers has afforded him
some nice perks
including this sprawling property north
of new york city
which comes with his own lake so
walden's i mean maybe the most important
book ever for you and now you have your
own pond see it is glamorous after all
hey kid writing is not all just hard
work there is a payoff here's the payoff
if it works well the finance job first
is also kind of working yes it turns out
while not completely intentional this
property is a call back of sorts to
toll's first novel when i wrote rules of
civility the culminating event takes
place at this adirondack house with a
great room and
on a lake and
years later we were looking for a house
in this neighborhood and we walked into
that living room where you and i were
speaking earlier and i was like oh my
god this is the living room and the book
and look at there's a lake outside and
you know so i was like whatever it takes
we're gonna let's this is great this is
it for me and so that house then uh it
reappears in the lincoln highway
it is here that tolls is already well
into the process of putting together his
next novel
and just as before
he's letting his imagination
lead the way did you expect all this
which
success oh
no you know i not no i you know i i
think
keith richards in his autobiography life
which is great
talks about returning home with mick
jagger because they grew up in the same
town
and he's walking down the street and you
know a young women who are his age come
out of the salon and say keith keith oh
you know can you know rockstar what are
you whatever can you could you ever have
imagined
and keith richards says uh
i i imagined it all
it's just that i never thought it would
happen once again keith richards says it
better than yes most anybody else can do
that's right
ain't that the truth uh yeah it is
indeed i haven't informed anymore yet
but he'll be hosting this saturday
morning retreat at his estate um this
year can i come yes you of course
um no seriously though the lincoln
highway is really it's it's a haunting
book
um but it's really worth a read i found
it uh after it was published um and just
loved it so much and like we gotta talk
to them i tell you you sit down with the
best and i always learn something new i
i'm dying to go
drive the lincoln heights i know right
it's sort of like not totally still
together but parts of it are and you
kind of want to i want to